Roxanne is up next Roxanne's in Kentucky
hey Roxanne what's up hello how are you
doing right how can we help thanks for
taking my call
I'll give you a quick a quick background
and then my question my husband is a
physician for 21 years in the past 10 to
12 years he's been making investments
often on stuff that I've known about
some that I haven't two years ago I
found out that he had taken out some
loans and credit cards without me
knowing and took out two hundred
eighty-seven thousand dollars in debt to
invest in a certain variety of things I
found out about it we paid it all down
we sold the house last year he said that
he would withhold the house and downsize
so we could pay off some of that debt or
pay off and he told me he wouldn't do it
again that he wouldn't make these
decisions without me doing it with my
knowledge and Saturday night I found out
that he had taken $45,000 against his
401k and made another investment in
December so as a Saturday I've been
living in the guest room and I'm not
sure where to go from here from now I
told him last time I did it I would
leave but I'm not sure if that's
something I should do or not do have you
guys seen a marriage counselor we went
one time and then last January and I
don't quite remember why we didn't go
back I honestly I don't think he really
wanted to go back I thought maybe he
could we could work it out ourselves so
we haven't no so if you were gonna call
him my name if you were gonna call him
names would you say he's a liar or he's
arrogant he lies to me a lot about
others and he oh yeah oh yeah like when
I asked him when did he make that when
he I found out Saturday he did the 401k
I said I assumed it was with the all the
other stuff two years ago and so I kind
of went outside
our work that night we're actually
listening to Dave Ramsey's on the
principle University Saturday night and
then it dawned on me I said when did you
take out this loan because you don't
have been paid back $800 in two years I
said when did you take this out he goes
oh I don't remember I said when did you
take out this long sometime in the past
I don't remember and I looked it up
because I figured out where it was it
was through his work and it was
different so yeah he's lied in the past
I'll say hey did work so I know about
non money things does he lie yeah I'll
say oh you stuck at work today is like
yeah it was a long day and then find out
later that he actually was out shopping
do different things has he cheated on
you before not cheap no what's cheap
cheap like a fare or anything no that's
not what about a history of addiction
addiction only is this money he wants to
get rich quick addiction is shopping at
discount stores and bringing home I mean
we have here's like 25 water bottles
you only mainly syllable water bottles
he has a diction of a good deal so I've
got to get it so this you called the
Aston question about money and all all
pipe in and Dave you've worked with
these these type situations for 30 years
this doesn't sound like about money at
all Dave Neil is about deception and
lying and really this is about fantasy
and so if if he hasn't if there's not a
history of infidelity also are also a
history of addiction I actually did some
research with a group I called them
resistant influentials which was doctors
and lawyers and presidents of things and
preachers folks who were real smart and
accomplished in one area of their life
and they like to drag that perceived
expertise all the way across they ended
up with a wake of broken marriages and
hurt people as I tried to take what they
perceived as this all-knowing power and
insight and wisdom into every facet of
their life the real question is you
can't make him stop and you have this
fantasy that it's going to get better
and this is my marriage is gonna look
like and at the end of the day you know
this but whining and nagging complaining
reasoning none of those behaviors will
make him stop he's got to decide it and
so I default back to a psychologist who
I love Terrence Rio who just says you've
got to draw a line you have to have a if
you don't this will happen statement and
then you've got to have done the math on
the backend both spiritually and
emotionally in and financially to say
here's here's my line here but the
reality is this is not gonna stop and it
clearly is not going to stop especially
I mean with the wounds of just coming
over two or three hundred thousand
dollars paying back and then hopping
right back in it prior so I keep hoping
that's gonna stop and it's not so I
don't know what I think the thing that's
missing out of this is you guys you guys
need someone in your life guiding you
and you don't have anybody there's no
one that he respects that is looking at
him saying you are a screw-up you are
messing up your life and so a good
counselor will gain his confidence not
with not with manipulation but just with
just with relationship and earn the
right to say that and say you are
screwing up your life and you're gonna
have to stop this a good pastor in his
life
a senior friend in his life that that
would that sit down and Whitin guide the
two of you that also would give you some
steps I would never tell you in a
two-minute synopsis of your life that
your marriage is over and you need to
leave unless he's hitting you and then
you need to get out of there but short
of that but you know what you're calling
about is to you're just trying to
confirm you're not crazy and you're not
but you do need but I wouldn't I
wouldn't just walk out I would do some
work on that solutely and go get some
help and if he won't go go by yourself
and get some guidance on how to draw the
lines that John is talking about okay
well I just I just actually found the
counselor for myself because I don't
even know how to approach this anymore
exactly how good so and I can't drag him
to counseling so maybe I should start
with my
that's fine absolutely.we article I'm
going to a counselor and we ought to go
to marriage counseling also there's
nothing wrong with doing both
simultaneously because you just need
some guides because both of you are you
know you just got a lot of trees around
you and it's hard to see the forest
right now and so you need someone to
walk with you through this and to give
you a thing of saying okay yeah you you
here you here's a map that is logical a
flowchart if you will it says if this
continues at this point I am done but
you can communicate that to him then and
it you know you've communicated it once
one time a long time ago and then now
you've got this one violation and but if
it's continually if there's a drumbeat
of this is how this works this is how
this works that's how that works and
because that's what happens with people
for instance that are married to an
alcoholic they come to the end mmm that
they've done all they're willing to do
and then that relationships over because
of the alcoholism and that's what's
gonna happen here you will come to the
end but you need to come there with a
guide you've got somebody I'd and with a
path of incremental and lots of
communication to him to where he doesn't
feel like you know here's another
example of that that is a parallel to
this when we have someone on our team
out of our thousand folks that is not
able to do the job or has some kind of a
behavior issue in the way they're acting
here at work we don't just walk in and
go surprised you're fired and we walk in
and go here's the things that you're
doing wrong here's what you're going to
have to not do is that you're going to
have to to do in order to be able to
stay and then the first time they're
half a button off of one of those we say
but timeout we said remember you gotta
get back get back in the lane get back
in the lane get back in the lane and and
what we will fire you over is not a
singular event unless it's a major issue
but we will fire you over a pattern that
is heading the wrong direction then we
have clearly communicated to you you are
heading down a road that leaves here now
do you want to stay on that road and
that's what you're
telling him but it's a it's a piece to
make the choice and then in a sense it's
the natural consequences of him not
dealing with it and Roxanne put him in
the guest room go back in your bedroom
he didn't get to sleep in the big bed
you do